[Music]
and welcome to our planning committee
meeting today
i can assure you it's nice to be here
before we begin i would like the
principal clerk to explain the health
and safety arrangements for the meeting
thank you chair so members have been
asked to take a lateral flow test before
attending this meeting and any members
you've recently contracted coping 19 um
needed to have tested negative on two
successive days to attend um we've got
the perspex theme screens in front of
you today um and also hand sanitizer for
your use um we would kindly ask if
members wouldn't congregate in the
chamber elsewhere in the building today
if possible and also in order to keep
numbers down within the chamber we do
have our offices joining us remotely um
via zoom thank you chair
thank you
item one on the agenda today is
apologies for absence
yes chair we've received apologies from
councillor peter elliott our councillor
david hancock and councillor maggie
jones
[Music]
item two declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
purely interest and or other interests
not already on their register of
interest in any item on the agenda and
withdraw from the meeting at the
appropriate time
do any members have any interest to
declare
none have been received here
thank you
item three
excuse me minutes of the last meeting we
now have the minutes of our meeting held
on tuesday the 22nd of february 2022
are we happy they are a correct record
and if they are is there a mover
thank you counselor second thank you all
those in favor
thank you
the motion has been carried
we move to the main business of the this
afternoon
we have just one application the late
representation reports and the report on
appeals lodged and determined
unhappy with this and intend to consider
the business in that order
before we begin i would like the clerk
to explain for the benefit of members
speakers and those watching the meeting
on youtube how we will deal with the
application thank you
thank you chair this is the procedure
for considering the application this
afternoon
the chair will introduce the application
then ask the planning officers to refer
members to any late comments or updates
received since the agenda was issued
the late items agenda supplement has
been published on the council's website
and hard copies have been circulated to
you
the planning officers will then give a
brief presentation
setting out the application plans and
photographs from the site
after this the chair will ask each of
the speakers to speak to the committee
each speaker will have three minutes to
put forward their views
there will be a reminder given by the
clerk when 30 seconds remain
at the end of the speaker's three
minutes
members of the committee will have an
opportunity to ask the speaker questions
if necessary in order to clarify any
points they have made
when we have heard from all of the
speakers on an application
the chair will open up the meeting for
debate by the committee
and ultimately determination by a vote
the votes will be taken by roll call
once the application which a speaker has
come to speak on has been dealt with
then they may leave the chamber
but if they choose to remain they will
not be allowed to participate further
from that point
now as you're aware this meeting is
being live streamed and according will
be placed on the council's website
please note that others may choose to
copy it
thank you chair
thank you
we'll now move to the application ned
forward slash 21 forward slash zero one
eight eight four slash fl
this is the proposed extension at the
peak edge hotel
in line with our normal practice i'm
going to ask the planning officers to
tell us about any late comments reports
that have been produced and to give a
brief presentation showing any photos
and plans of the site
i will allow the officers to complete
their presentation consequently members
could you please reserve any points of
order or questions about the process
until the end
there will be plenty of time for
questions later
graeme i believe you're doing the
presentation
just before graham comes in chad we've
just got one further late reps to report
to members that was received at six
o'clock last night so it wasn't
included in the late comment report that
members received yesterday afternoon
share the representation comes from a mr
round who lives on matlock road and he
states that the scheme has business and
employment merits and improves on the
original lodge scheme
however in his opinion there are main
objections to the scale of this proposal
and its effect on the local area the
primary concern that he has is with
water supply water supply in the areas
via boreholes springs or wells
the proposal would put pressure on this
in his view especially in the dry summer
months
potentially restricting water to others
and potentially making other properties
uninhabitable
it also raises the issue of foul
drainage chair and he says that foul
drainage should be managed such that
this
is
leading to no contamination of the
ground or water supplies
and finally he says if the development
does go ahead
he will hold the developer and involve
councils jointly responsible for any
impact on the quality and quantity of
water supply in any contamination
just to clarify those points chair these
issues are addressed in the officer
report
i'm happy to take any questions as
appropriate later and now i'll hand over
to graham he'll take you through the
various elements of the application
thank you when you're ready graham
hello could everybody see my screen just
having a few issues
can everybody see that yep you're up and
running
okay excellent so good afternoon members
i hope you're all all right
so the first item as has just been
discussed is the proposed extension to
hotel to include 29 additional bedrooms
and a spa suite with a small pool and
treatment rooms and associated
alterations to the adjacent landscape
including creation of a new biodiversity
area with pond buns and planting
this is a major development and we've
received amended plans and this is at
the peak edge hotel dali road
at hashover
so this first slide you can see this
highlights the site there's no special
graeme
apologies
graham we can see your screen but not
the slides
yeah i'm not sure what's happening so
just bow in one second
[Music]
just borrow me a second it seems to have
gone a bit haywire
is that better yeah that's it jackpot so
apologies about that
so can everybody see the site location
plan
that's fine perfect so yeah apologies
for that so the this first slide you can
see the site
edged in orange you can see the existing
hotel
and the public house
where the land holding extends to the
south
you've got darley road
here to the north of the site and you've
got matlock road here to the east
to the immediate east of the site is
property called myrtle grove
that's this property here
you've also got a barn that's been
recently being converted into a dwelling
that sits there
and to the west of the site you've got a
few more a range of properties here
and as you go up belland lane
you've got you can see here down in the
bottom left-hand corner of the screen
this is a stone edge smelt mill that's a
scheduled ancient monument
and as you move along the road here
you've got a number of other properties
that
are just outside the shot here to the
south of the application site
so this is just a clearer site plan an
existing arrangement on site
next slide this is the
proposed extension to the hotel this is
the amended scheme that we're
considering today
so the original scheme kind of followed
the edge of the boundary site the
amended scheme has just been
just been turned slightly and pivoted
away from the boundary just to take into
account some issues that we had with
potential for noise and outlook issues
from the upper floor balcony that's been
removed from the site and moved to the
western
roof slope
you can see on the proposal we've got
this landscaped area
we've got some kind of raised bonding
and a wildlife pond
hopefully that's clear
so these are the proposed elevations for
the hotel you can see
the proposal as amended includes ground
and first floor accommodation
with balconies upper floor balconies as
i've just mentioned
in the roof space have been shifted from
the eastern elevation just to the west
and the extension will be constructed
from coarse stone and
slate roof
so this next slide this illustrates the
proposed spa which will be constructed
again from coarse stone
and it'll have feature glazing and
timber framework just have a lighter
lighter kind of feel to the main
extension
so the next elevation plan this is the
proposed extension and its relationship
with existing hotel so you can see the
proposal here in the top right
and this is the existing hotel and
pub complex with various extensions
added on over the years
so the next few slides these are some
visualizations provided by the applicant
so this is the entrance into the
extended hotel which will be from the
car park you can just make out in the
bottom right hand corner you've got a
little plan so the little red dot just
shows where the photograph is kind of
taken to give that visualization
so this next one from the south west
just looking back towards the spa area
and the little little sunken terrace
this is just another angle of the spa
this is from the west looking across
the existing pond that's already on site
back towards the spa in the hotel
extension
this one is just another alternate view
from the south east towards the spa
and then this final one is
this this is the penultimate apology so
this is just another spa i know the
angle of the spa building so
the final visualization is just an
internal shot just for artist impression
really just give you an idea of what
that space will feel like
so this slide is is quite important and
is referred to in the officer report so
this is a slide to show the plan of the
2015 extant permission which was granted
by members of planning committee in 2016
you can see that the proposal includes
an engineered road
and 20 lodges
located to the south of the application
site
so to be clear the applicant is willing
to enter into a unilateral undertaking
legal agreement with the council
to not build this scheme out in return
for the proposed extension
being approved today so hopefully that's
that's quite clear of what was approved
in 2016.
and this is just one photo from
yesterday so members that attended the
virtual site visit yesterday will have
seen a kind of comprehensive set of
photos i just thought this one was
probably the most important
and this is a view from belland lane
looking north towards the application
site you can see the existing
like the pub and the hotels extension
there
the proposal will just extend in this
area here
you can see myrtle grove to the east
the boundary treatments and the barn
conversion a little bit further along
and sure that concludes the presentation
thank you
and we'll move to our first speaker
which is the applicant mr perez
[Music]
mr perez you have three minutes when
you're ready
microphone on
good afternoon chair members of the
planning committee and the planning
department
thank you for considering my application
today
most of you will be aware i'm a local
businessman
uh all my businesses are based here in
north derbyshire including global brands
her drinks company
which is basically play cross and also
the casa hotel
my father santi owned the red line back
in the 70s
and it was best restaurant in the area
they often own the famous red line
unfortunately he died when i was just 19
and business was sold
i have lived in the area stone and stone
age for most of my life
i eventually built my successful drinks
business and the casa hotel which you
many will know and agree it is a great
asset to the town
and we employ 350 people
i bought the peak edge hotel over four
years ago and i was initially very
excited about the lodges
however as i developed the business and
the food in particular food and beverage
i found there's great demand greater
demand for high quality accommodation
and also leisure
i also had many discussions with local
residents some who were very concerned
about the visual impact of the lodges
so i then looked a scheme to increase
the number of bedrooms instead of the
lodges and then working with the
planning authority and the midland
design panel and my own design team
to exchange a plane commission for the
lodges and we can't eventually came up
with a scheme you have today
my aim is to build the only five-star
hotel in derbyshire and fill the gap in
the market where there's a lack of
top-quality accommodation particularly
in north east derbyshire and play cross
i want to have a hotel and facilities
i'm personally very proud of and a
center of hospitality excellence
we're very fortunate age in chesterfield
to have a great catering college and
a fantastic beauty therapy college
and and we already work at global brands
and and the hotels uh on training and
apprenticeships
this will provide additional career
opportunities to many local people
and and and also help the local tourism
market
our business plan show will
generate
49 full-time equivalent jobs
as well 30 seconds remain as well as
encouraging tourists to the area which
will benefit existing and local business
and tourist attractions
we're very keen to work with the parish
council and your local community
projects
and i believe my design is sustainable
and in keeping with the area and will
give many people the opportunity to
enjoy our beautiful county
our lovely countryside and it'll be a
fantastic local facility for the
community
thank you are there any questions
council armitage
thank you chair
uh
how many uh people do you employ at the
moment at the peak age had to pick about
50
right
so you're going to increase it by a
number of how many by another 49 right
so you're nearly doubling it yeah
because because the uh because it will
be a 24
7 day a week operation
and also because of the spa
we'll need a beauty therapist and
treatment specialist and because we want
to go for the a
five-star rating that means we have to
improve the quality for example we have
to have a
concierge on all night we have to have
we have to give 24-hour room service
so it'd be quite labor-intensive
thank you
any other questions
thank you mr perez
[Music]
charlotte you know the drill
thank you
[Music]
thank you it's been a pleasure to work
on this design-led scheme we hope you
can see the quality from the images
we've shown
this includes elements such as glazing
setback to reduce light spillage
a thorough design review panel event was
held at the pre-application stage
the application includes a design and
access statement planning statement
transport statement design strategy
heritage impact assessment ecology
reports and a detailed landscape master
plan
at 8.9 your office of your officer
report it is confirmed there are no
technical drainage water supply
contamination or stability concerns
the borehole water supply will be
upgraded with a new pump
at 7.77 of the report it is confirmed
that water supply is covered by separate
legislation and licensing
there will be a new significant wildlife
area to the east and the scheme would
achieve biodiversity net gain derbyshire
wildlife trust have welcomed the
proposals
the scheme was amended to reposition the
extension and move the top floor
balconies to the other side of the
building to reduce any perceived impact
on the neighbour
the neighbouring house is 48 metres from
the boundary and 100 metres from the spa
the applicants wish to create a tranquil
experience for their guests there will
be no noise issue for the neighbours
this extension would be built instead of
the lodges you've previously approved
we have already submitted a completed
legal agreement which ensures that the
scheme of 20 two-story lodges will not
be constructed if this extension is
built
the family lodges would be spread out
across the fields to the south of the
hotel whereas the extension would be
positioned much closer to the existing
buildings
the floor area of the extension is
smaller than the 20 lodges and the use
of the lodges would cause more
disturbance potentially
your planning officers national park
authority councils independent landscape
consultant and the county council
heritage advisor all agree that the
current proposal would have
significantly less impact than the
approved lodges
the committee report doesn't identify
any significant areas of harm
the benefits far outweigh any harm and
these are some of the benefits
a sustainable high quality design work
for local contractors 49 jobs including
apprenticeships increased tourism
increased weddings and other events
which benefit local businesses such as
florist
photographers
high quality spa facilities a brand new
wildlife site and extensive native tree
planting a truly five-star venue
northeast derbyshire can be proud of we
ask you to support the proposal thank
you
thank you are there any questions
excuse me chad just before members go on
uh just for the record that was
charlotte stanton who's the um
agent for the application thank you
no questions thank you charlotte thank
you
are there any questions for the officers
planning officers
councillor hall
yeah thank you in our um
late next place sorry i'll just find it
one of the comments was from a neighbor
and
it's about
sorry let me just find it
on page six second down it says well for
where the first dot is in dealing with a
previous proposal for detached garage
with a room above
at our property we were required to
reduce the size of the building and to
remove the proposed balcony in order to
reduce any intrusion to the countryside
this judgment
on balcony should be consistent between
applications on adjoining sites
uh i just wondered what uh what
comparison there we have to take into
account on this the previous application
sorry i've literally just read this late
comment so um
but i've not got my ipad to compare so
so what what do we have to take into
account between this previous
application on another site and the one
before us please
which one of you gentlemen want to uh
answer that i don't find it really
relevant at this point because the
balconies have been changed to overlook
any properties
okay if i can perhaps perhaps start and
try and assist castle and if graham's
got something further he might come in
following that but as we often advise
planning committee each application
needs to be considered on its own merits
in light of the development plan and the
relevant policies and our assessment of
this proposal is based on
the council's up-to-date local plan and
its policies in particular in respect to
to tourism
in respect of other applications it's
difficult to transpose issues that were
considered as part of what i presume was
a household replication and i don't know
enough details
um in respect of that to assist mr hall
sorry council hall with the the exact
details
but in terms of design and impact in
terms of the householder
application it will be similar
consideration in terms of the wider
impact of extensions to that property
i presume a much smaller property in
that case in this instance where you're
talking about a different
set of circumstances relating to the
application in particular as well chair
i'd draw members attention to the issues
that graham mentioned earlier and also
set out in the report regarding the
fallback position
and certainly in this instance
we are placing weight on that whereas in
respect to the issue that counts the
hall raised i don't know if that would
have been a consideration in that
instance
i hope that helps
yeah i'll just chip in there if that's
okay just uh just to be clear i think
that
the upper floor balconies were moved
from the eastern elevation to the west
so there's still our ground on first
floor balconies but we took the view
that
the impact would not be detrimental on
neighboring residents immunity and
privacy
hope that clears that up
okay thank you
are there any further questions
no thank you i'll open the floor for
debate if anyone wants to
council armitage
thank you chair
i remember when i was on the committee
when the first one uh
was approved and yes there were
one or two uh problems which were
overcome and it was uh passed i don't
know if it was unanimous i can't
remember quite
that far back
as far as this application uh is
concerned as far as i'm concerned it
it's far superior to what was uh
first done with the actual bungalows
it'll enhance
the
amenities in the area
and
as far as
there's a load of trees which were put
in before
and this is uh
it's they've grown up now and
i mean the photographs don't really show
them in their uh full light because
they're they're not in leaf but uh i can
assure you that when they are in leave
uh
you know it uh adds to the uh what
should i say the landscape area and the
impact that it has
uh
it
it is a plan which will help the rural
economic economy both in the terms of
people that it's going to uh have
working there the increase of 40 odd
people you know that's a heck of a lot
uh
and also there'll be local suppliers who
will uh supply them
and i think the benefits of this far
away
far outweigh any of the problems which
have been brought up uh
with the uh water and uh sewage disposal
and one thing in another
he's already said that uh they're gonna
put a bigger pump in
uh so it you know
i've had uh
experience with boreholes having put one
in
uh on my farm and
yes there are lots and lots of rules and
regulations which you have to adhere to
and
it you know
what you do with yourself well i never
had one
that ran dry and were using a hell of a
lot of water uh i mean it was supplied
120 dairy cows and quite frankly they
drink something like 20 gallons of water
each a day
so
they we overcame any problems with those
and i'm sure that any problems can be
overcome here because if there was a
problem who was it going to affect most
mr perez and his business so he's going
to make sure there's plenty of water
there
and as for the swimming pool and what
i'll be well it's an asset to the hotel
and we should go for it we need a
five-star hotel in northeast derbyshire
plus there isn't one
and uh i support this uh
application but i'm not going to move it
just yet okay thank you
is there anybody else want to put in for
the debate
council hearts hall
uh yeah really just to agree with
a lot of the sentiments that williams
said i think the benefits of this
proposal
far outweigh
any detriment to our impact so
i'm supportive of it
thank you thank you if there's nobody
else ready for debate i'm going to
propose that we actually accept the main
recommendations by the officers to grant
permission subject to the conditions and
the legal agreement
is there a seconder yeah
thank you councillor armitage
thank you for members could clearly
state fought against or abstain
counselor armitage
four councillor cooper
councillor foster
four councillor hall
four council hearts one
four councillor liggett
for councillor powell
four councillor ridgeway
four councillor rouse four and
councillor rough four as you know mr
chair thank you thank you very much and
good luck
thank you
adrian do you want to take us through uh
item six planning appeals
our wheelchair is there's very little to
report as members will know we've just
had the
three appeals that have been lodged in
the past four weeks although members
will note that over the past
three days i think we've had two appeals
that have been handed down to us and
we'll report those in due course and
comment as appropriate chair but i'm
happy to take any questions if members
have any
any questions for adrian
no thank you
i have no urgent business
so thank you all very much um alan is
ricky going to do a presentation uh as i
understand it chair yes um i'm not sure
whether he's actually online yet but we
can uh soon get him online
if members should just bear with us a
few minutes thank you thank you
[Music]
you